hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well is there anything
wrong with utilitarianism anything in
the theory or in its implications where
you said I don't like this I think that
they're going off-track here or this
would be less you this would be a
dangerous thing for people to actually
take as their amoral guidance was there
anything about
do they have things all spit down yeah
pleasure you can even like you bad
things to yourself weirder things that
people do like that like it was really
entertaining for me to torture myself
like broadcasted on the Internet and
like make millions of people happy by
doing that then maybe it sounds like
that would be a great thing that's of
utilitarian to do just my pain
anything else
we'll get more more dyslexic when the
letters in the wrong place
okay something wrong my friend that's
that's a pretty important one it's hard
to apply in some respects you have to
like figure out how every possible
person would be affected if you're going
to really do it
wave on to them you probably have to
print out a lot of those handouts those
worksheets that I made you guys be able
to go to latarian and care we're out of
your bag or four guys maybe yourself a
legal pad and carry them around using
them what else what are other what are
other things are structured yet I don't
know if they considered like alternative
versus talked about that he he does note
that we should give greater weight to
short term and pleasure them to the long
term pleasure or pain together well
that's yeah you want to say that we
should pay more attention long term
anything else that made you nervous or
suspicious or where you said I think
they're just wrong guys
but there any values or goods that might
you think a really important might be
sacrificed particularly cemetery
perspective it's probably good to go
yeah I mean there might be situations in
which you are like the person receiving
a pleasure
like from utilitarian perspective you
might have to sacrifice in order like
achieve the greatest good and that
doesn't make sense
I mean you never expect it like that's
good enough get out of this okay so the
these are some good objections these are
some real issues they're not the only
ones that could be raised but I think
that these are pretty common ones that
come up and what we want to ask is can
mill address these sorts of things some
of these he actually does address and
the criticisms of a look at in just a
minute but I wanted to get your
criticisms because I think it's
important to make this content it's
important ranges things like that so
this is always gonna be a problem it
looks like you can do layout of things
as the pleasure the neck pleasure
hallway is the pain so we can do things
horrible things to people that might be
lasting entire life for example we have
about 20 people in this classroom let's
say we're now a community and we're
gonna live together the rest of our
lives now we could do things
democratically and elect a leader and
you know I kept representation and work
things up by consensus and like you know
divvy up the jobs and each person takes
a turn but let's say that I just seize
power because I don't you know I'm the
professor and
I say you know I think what best for the
community would be under this sign over
you guys are enough slaves now the rest
of us are gonna take it easy because
you're gonna do all the work all the
time your life
I'm very sorry too you know you
shouldn't stand on that side today you
know it's an unfortunate luck of the
draw your life is going to be crap from
the mock opinion very little pleasure
because the pleasure is going to be for
us but look there's like three times as
many of us as there are review so who
works out so much better for everybody
what we're all you know if there's any
consolation in that it's that you're
contributing to the greater good your
whole life then you know they're not
going to like that right they're like I
don't want to get a slave this is a
crappy deal for me or any of the rest
you bothered by this notion that now
that your life is going to be enjoyable
because we're gonna make them work like
dogs and deprive them of all sorts of
pleasures because there's three times as
many of those if you're bothered by that
then this is a real objection because it
kind of doesn't Mills not going to
respond to that criticism and the stuff
that we're looking at in this section
he's gonna respond to that and this
stuff about justice hard to follow
because everyone it takes everyone into
account this is falling into the sort of
genre of criticism it's just too tough
to apply and that's a that's a criticism
that does get made a authoritarianism if
you worry actually think about if you
did not only have to take everybody into
account what does that mean you actually
have to figure out everybody's pleasures
and pains to do a lot of empirical
research in order to make this work then
you have to like you know make your best
guests
can you imagine like whipping out some
ledger sheet every time you have to make
a moral decision about what you ought to
do be very practical wouldn't it also
there would be unpleasurable the theory
itself would dampen the amount of
pleasure will come back to them not
enough weight given to long term
pleasures milk and dress that mill says
that we ought to be thinking about the
happiness involved in a whole human life
so that one will be addressed and then
finally you might have to sacrifice your
only happiness for others they act as an
interesting objection because from
utilitarian perspective your brother
there will be cases where the right
thing to do might even not just be your
own happiness your own life right have
to sacrifice your own life your own
ideals in order to benefit the community
does that is that a reason to not be
utilitarianism let's leave that one
hanging here now let's look at the
criticisms that no takes on
and I have seven of them listed one of
which we're going to defer first one is
this sort of you got things totally
wrong until Oteri's so you know when we
hear about utilitarian design or taking
a Tillett area approach to things a lot
of times people think that means leaving
out ornamentation or beauty we're
heading the things that we take pleasure
yeah I won't you know if I had a tie on
today you know we did something that'll
keep my neck warm and don't worry about
whether it actually matches my clothes
or not
thing with you know polka that side
flowers utilitarian it'd be like look
it's a tie sergey's purpose just fine it
doesn't matter how well utilitarians do
it actually care for pleasure give an
artistic lecture right you could be in
the fashion industry Andy it's a
material you could be a musician and a
utilitarian you just want to create the
most pleasure for everyone so if you are
a musician you might not play the violin
you might play the electric guitar
instead because you can probably please
more people more quickly learning guitar
than you can buy them things like that
so that's an easy objection to deal with
another popular objection is materials
so I think it's a philosophy fit for
pigs its animalistic it's just these
plunger speakers and that's all they
care about they don't care about anybody
else is affected or you know whether
they cultivate themselves or about
education or you know family life it's
just give me as much pleasure as
possible where your let's spread out as
much pleasure as possible let's just you
know drink and eat and have sex and
sleep in and otherwise do nothing and
that'll be like the ideal existence
cultivation what about mobility what
about you know what's distinctively
human little is an answer so I'm going
to I'm going to put that one on off
presenter that's a big answer some
people say happiness
the goal this is an interesting
projection
notice that none of you made this
objection because you probably all do
believe that happiness is gold there are
some people who say happiness is just
unattainable you can never really be
happy so long forget trying to make
people happy some people say you know
what right do you have to be happy you
you're lucky you even exist
who are you talking about pleasure pain
put things in perspective and then other
people say you know if you want to
actually develop as a human being you
need to engage in renunciation and
giving things up so that you can develop
virginals moral character
you know these are the parents who take
away they get the kid candy and then
take it away and say toughen up this is
gonna be good for you and that you know
what kind of kid does that turn out to
be dull the other kid only wants all the
candy bars in the store or another
another person who don't like takes
candy bars away from the kids and says
toughen up no so wait a second why can't
happiness be the goal for rational human
life it is possible yeah
and who are you to want to be happy well
you're a human being that's the way
because I work we do want to be yeah so
it's kind of nonsensical to say why are
you entitle to be happy and then you
know what about this renunciation why do
people give things up what you know what
are things that you have given them
you've all given up you know doing
whatever the hell you want by becoming
Mehra students it goes through all sorts
of things
all the time like doing homework showing
up to class you know I'm sure some of
you have jobs that you've got to show up
to it you can't just wear whatever you
like or do whatever you like or say
whatever you like you've given a lot of
things haven't you why let's just take
going America
why are you good sitting here to the
ethics class a lovely afternoon and
beautiful following lots of Malory when
you could be outside having a great time
up here very for your future okay now
why do you value that greater future
because it's going to be more sacrifices
and pronunciation it's going to offer me
the chance to renounce things and to
make myself miserable on it put the even
greater scale that your job plan for an
Indian okay
let me talk to you after class I'm
trying to talk to you how about I'm not
even a utilitarian that would be crazy
from other perspectives because you
think it's gonna make you happy right
going into Marist if it's not making you
happy already
and it could is going to be part of your
greater happiness so you know sacrifice
we make sacrifices for the sake of
happiness not just to say there is no
such thing here's another
utilitarianism makes makes us look at
each transaction of the glue into what
is the greatest good that's gonna come
out of this
how should I calculate this should I go
to my kids recital or should I sit home
and play video games or go out to the
bar with my friends will it's going to
give the greatest happiness the greatest
balance of pain or pleasure pleasure
overpaid to the community at large it's
just one kid he's gonna be buried into
your shoes gonna be very disappointed
but you know if I go and hang out at the
bar with all my friends they're gonna be
very happy there's something weird about
somebody who would actually think things
out that way and then decide not to go
to the kids recital we're not to go to
the bar I won't go to the bar because
there would be a greater quantum of
unhappiness created for my kid and for
my spouse and Happiness this auric
nonsense from for me from making the
calculations before then the
quantitative pleasure that would be
created in the bar friends now does that
strike you the way does that strike you
as a real criticism utilitarians are all
gonna behave this way we're not going to
they're not going to be concerned about
personal relationships or you know your
friends or qualities there's no
necessary this is not a criticism I'll
use this up here
utilitarianism is a fabulous in the
sense that it doesn't rely on any
revealed religious principles
remember Bentham and mill are writing to
a society of people who routinely do
read the Bible and view Christianity is
that you know this sort of developed
pinnacle of religion and also of
morality and we've lost quite a bit of
that in our culture but there's still a
lot of people who see things like that
so maybe if you're looking at
utilitarianism say I don't need this
I've got the Bible I've got the Ten
Commandments or I don't see you talking
about and God's important to me and
God's important to a lot of other people
too
so where are you gonna bring that yeah
well Mill says it's not really godless
it just credits God with being a
utilitarian you might that might strike
you did I but you know think this
through from utilitarian perspective if
God is a good god I was not going to
behave him how is God gonna want us to
be here is God gonna really want us to
single out just a few people free
happiness and say the rest of those
bastards let that burn or is God gonna
wants to promote human happiness I mean
if you read the Gospels this Jesus guy
he sure seems to be about making people
happier doesn't he he heals people their
illnesses he doesn't say software that's
good for you he heals him and presumably
that's a good thing even he was like
people that see it's come there are
other people want associate
everyone smiling it's mad and you know
with some money changers or things yeah
but on the whole B's you know I've been
in futility look at the big picture
these counseling be nice to other people
right treat them well called the naked
feed the hungry do the sort of things
that are useful to utilitarian so I
leave this up to you to decide whether
until the Terry doesn't really look that
much like Christianity because I think
there's a little bit more to the story
yeah but that's that's where middle is
going another criticism is that the
utilitarian relies on what's expedient
rather that principle this was this is
another variation of the utilitarian ISM
will allow us to do bad things that go
against moral principles because they're
useful because they benefit more people
overall than they are so if we want it
to engage in volume say for example
right
pick something ran
consider your sunglasses with both got
sunglasses what can a pendant decide
whether what stones all right let's all
pick out the turquoise pendant wearing
person and make fun of her and you know
we'll have a good time at your expense
yeah it'll pay off in greater pleasure
than pain why does that strike you as
being dead because somebody told you
don't bully other people right that's
that's a moral principle for you I think
maybe we can trace that back to other
principles we should have treat people
unfairly doesn't it look like
utilitarianism requires us to give up
these principles yeah I mean that's not
really an objection we're gonna find out
that utilitarianism shows us that most
principles are are useful to us
most of these principles are held to be
good because they produce greater
pleasure over pain finally
you can't be Tillett area because you'd
have to carry out these utilitarian it's
a look
utility calculations every time you get
into a situation and who's got the time
for that and where are you going to get
all this information from you'd have to
be like a super computer now does that
strike you as a valid objection yeah I
think yeah because it's appalling to
follow what you tell you solitary isn't
actually like it's finally like the
guyline love it
you couldn't well is it possible to
follow something generally without
actually being a yourself yeah I would
say that he follows some of its
principles rather than actually being
able call yourself but you know
millville makes an interest in
comparison here he says think about
Christians did they whip out the Bible
and consult the entirety of the old and
new Testament in every single case where
they
to do the Christian thing they never get
done
listen let's just say there weren't any
contradictions between different cases
and principles it would be an incredibly
cumbersome way to do things do we say
that people don't behave in a Christian
manner because of that they follow
general guidelines yeah they they even
just following the stuff that it says in
the Sermon on the Mount if you ever look
at those rules about things those are
tough and they're mostly about how to do
good other people you know the attitudes
so many strikes you have a cheek turn
the cheek there's you know there's
things about well that doesn't mean
doing it forever yeah I'm a hard time
you're just turning at once I think a
lot of people do does that mean that
they're not endorsing Christianity or
they're not behaving like a Christian
they don't follow every single thing if
we look at utilitarianism that way then
maybe that objection isn't a strong
objection maybe we should try to do that
in cases where we have the time we
should do stuff we should see how much
people are there but if I got to decide
on the spot if I mean utilitarian
tonight to decide on the spot of a
trolley problem you know it's one person
versus five people perhaps even myself
into one person I can make a split I can
make a split-second decision
and make the right decisions I'm
following the general guidelines of the
greatest happiness possible